- All right, everybody we've
reached the end of the hour,
but we have time for one more
story that may make you happy.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(audience cheers)
So if you know me at all, you know
I'm a huge sports ball fanatic,
but this is really cool.
Tomorrow actually does
mark the 75th anniversary
of Jackie Robinson
breaking the color barrier
for Major League Baseball.
(audience cheers)
- It happened on April 15th, 1947,
when he took the field
as the first baseman
for the Brooklyn Dodgers.
75 years later, y'all,
the Los Angeles Dodgers,
as well as the entire league,
are honoring number 42 in a huge way.
Here to talk about it is the manager
for the Dodgers, Dave Roberts,
who watches on NBC Four, Los Angeles.
- What's up Dave?
(audience cheers)
What's up Dave?
So Jackie Robinson's
legacy is still a big part
of baseball and the
Dodgers as well, right?
- It is, Kelly.
And thank you so much for
having me join you guys.
And I remember when
Jackie Robinson, talking
to Sharon Robinson and
being a ball player,
former ball player, every single day now,
Jackie Robinson Day.
Every player wears number 42
to commemorate Jackie Robinson.
And I'll tell you this,
that the great Dr. Martin Luther King said
he would not have been
able to do what he did
for civil rights if it
weren't for Jackie Robinson.
(audience cheers)
So I'm a big legacy guy, and
no one has a bigger legacy
than Jackie.
- That's amazing.
And what a cool honor.
So how are y'all gonna
be honoring him tomorrow?
- So it's, I'm excited.
I mean, for me to be able
to, I'm a former Bruin,
and I played at Jackie Robinson Stadium.
So tomorrow night at
Dodger Stadium at 7:10,
the first 40,000 fans are gonna get a
75th anniversary commemorative jersey,
Jackie Robinson.
- Wow.
- 42 jersey, which is gonna be so special.
So they're gonna be rocking 42 jerseys all
over Dodger stadium.
And also, the Dodger,
Jackie Robinson Scholar
Foundation is gonna
bring 75 people, Kelly.
42 people that have kind of
gone through that system,
and 33 young kids that are still
at John Muir High School,
that are still part of that program.
So the Dodgers, the Jackie
Robinson Foundation,
do so much, Kelly, in the
community, for the kids.
And that's me right there.
I had all of our players do the unveiling
of Jackie Robinson.
And it was more of just talking
to guys that, we wear this Dodger jersey
but that's the OG, the person,
and what Jackie Robinson stood for.
And I think that when
you're a better player,
you understand and appreciate the guys,
the people that came before
us, it just makes us better.
And no one exuded that more than Jackie.
(audience cheers)
- That's amazing.
Thank you so much, Dave.
- I'm liking the post right now.
That's not all, everybody.
Our season-long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of Frixion,
the go-to erasable pen, of
the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly,
just like Jackie Robinson did.
So they're gonna donate a thousand dollars
to the Jackie Robinson Foundation.
(audience cheers)
- Thank you for joining us, Dave.
I'll see you at a game.